John you have spent a lot of time with
Kit Harington I think he's the only cast
member I have not personally met is he
as good looking in person as he appears
on television oh this guy but this guy I
mean I mean seen him on screen is nice
enough right yeah it's nothing compared
to what I'm gonna call the live
experience nothing like it it's a bit
like only ever seeing the Mona Lisa as a
JPEG on somebody's phone somebody says
what do you think you know yeah it's a
pretty good painting yeah yeah not blown
away by it yeah then you see in real
life thing about good lord
yeah but the thing about him that so
frustrating is he's a man of absolutely
no compromise either there's a selfie of
us that I put on my Instagram where
we're both kind of leaning in and I'm
doing puppy dog because kind of all I've
got right
don't even doing puppy dog like this
we will do more puppy dog and then I say
right cheers mate thanks for that and
look at it and these dream puppy dog as
well yeah and that don't do puppy dog as
well I wouldn't do puppy doggy like
those at my stick you can't have abs and
puppy dog yeah you've got to make a
choice otherwise it just looks like yeah
yeah yeah he got a double dose at the
fact that yeah cause of all the good
stuff he's right in the sweet spot
between good-looking vulnerable smart
talented yeah you seem bitter about this
she'd leave me with one fish
you